serena leah lovely to see you uh here we
are um serena just
what 10 months ago you walked out of
wembley on in your first week and you
told us that you hoped you get england
to the final of the euros
how difficult how arduous how much of a
task has it been to get england here
well we've had a lot of tests uh
um but i think we did pretty well i
think the season has been really good
for us um and i think um the group stage
went
relatively easy well it looks easy it's
never easy
and um well we've all seen that the
spain game was really tight and close so
that was a very exciting one too and um
sweden looked a little easier but we had
moments in the game that we had a little
hard time but also moments that we
really dominated and i had a good score
so here we are now
you've said you just alluded to it there
you face moments of diversity on the
field you face moments can you please of
course thank you you face moments of
adversity on the field
you face some difficult times off the
field as a group as well has that put
you in a better place going into this
this final
yeah it's just really good to get all
these experiences um so what we're
trying to do before this tournament in
preparation to to try to figure out what
can we expect on and off pitch
and if you prepare really well then uh
you you
some of those situations will occur too
and then we we at least know how we
could react on that and how we could
take that um
so i think the team has done really well
um and i think we even we grew
throughout the season but i think we
grew even more in this competition so
far
you know i'm going to ask you about team
selection so
look we saw all 23 players trained
earlier can we expect any changes
tomorrow
well i don't want to say anything about
that
everyone is fit we'll make hard choices
and we know how strong our squad is that
we have lots of opportunities of players
to play
leah
you are probably one of the biggest
england fans i know
you talked about your journey from going
from
six minutes to tournament football to
where you are now
how have you again can you even
visualize how it's gonna
see feel tomorrow when you lead england
out at a packed out wembley
uh no um
none of us have been in that position
before um in that team to walk out on
this stage so it'll be a new one for all
of us but i think
what happens in a tournament is you grow
gay bike game by game and i think
the opportunity that i've had for growth
in this tournament has
given me confidence i think that
tomorrow i'll be ready uh for whatever
emotion or or feelings come my way i
don't need to tell you what it means to
play in the final but this is germany
germany like does it add a little bit
more spice i don't want a little bit
more of a kind of fear factor going into
this considering
you know what they bring in their
mentality and all those kind of things i
think it's a good narrative
for you guys obviously it's a fairy tale
a fairy tale fixture with the history
behind it but i think for us
uh you would never expect to get to a
final without playing
the best team in the tournament and as
you know in terms of i think
the journey that both of us have been on
you've got the two two teams that have
had the best tournaments in the final
which is the best thing so i think this
is what we expected to come up against
the team playing their best football and
luckily we're playing ours soon is that
what you agree with the best germany are
the best team in the tournament
well when you read the final
then you're one of the best teams in the
tournament i think we have a very good
team too and we don't fear anyone